so getting into part three of our
discussion on atom brashear the story
actually shifts its focus away from Tony
Stark's search for blue Marvel and
focuses in Adams life after he was asked
to step down by President Kennedy
picking up with a man named general
Mason who as far as I know exists only
within the context of this story the
indication seems to be that in addition
to asking blue Marvel to step down
President Kennedy authorized the United
States military to keep an eye on blue
Marvel to ensure that he did not become
a credible threat to the United States
now the reason why the United States
military was chosen to do this is that
if you recall our last video we had
talked about how shield was given the
opportunity but ultimately turned it
down due to the fact that neither Nick
Fury nor any of his subordinates agreed
with what had been done to blue Marvel
now something that's really interesting
here is that Griffo does not depict the
situation as the US military against
blue Marvel instead he provides us with
a real-world scenario and that while
those in the military are required to
follow the orders handed down to them
not everyone agrees with what's going on
as some of the soldiers state if the
government is concerned about blue
Marvel it would make more sense and be
more appropriate to subtly ask him to
work for the government especially
considering the fact that he's done so
much to protect the world bringing in a
woman named Marlene Frazier at the time
of her first meeting with military
intelligence she's established as being
relatively neutral with regards to blue
Marvel himself now this is something
done intentionally by Kevin Grove oh and
we'll actually find out why later in
this series but the superior of Marlene
is against the idea of sending her on
her mission now in terms of his
depiction a groove Oh actually leads it
to us to decide if this man is racist or
not and that he stayed so the culture of
african-americans is different from that
of whites while this is a true statement
the context of the situation is
ambiguous and that this man is not
talking among his friends and nothing
he's saying
is explicitly racist in and of itself
but the result of the meeting is that
Marlene is being tasked with engaging in
a relationship with blue Marvel for the
purpose of monitoring him now at this
point we jump to the current day with
Marlins entire story being provided to
blue Marvel firsthand now the reaction
of blue Marvel during the conversation
is exactly what we would expect and that
he's basically learning that the entire
marriage between himself and Marlene was
rooted in deception
the perspective of Adam he was more like
a personal project for Marlene rather
than an actual love interest something
that's compounded on when she reveals
that she had spent all of her time
reading up on everything about Adam
prior to meeting him for the first time
where Marlene pleads her case and saying
that at the time she was operating in
the interest of her country for Adam all
of this is irrelevant the reason why is
that in addition to learning that his
marriage is a lie after everything he
had done for the United States and in
the world in the end the government
still didn't trust him however for
Marlene while her original intention was
to prove her worth as a spy as time
progressed she developed an actual love
towards Adam while some of this was due
to the time they spent together it was
also due to the experiences the two of
them shared as they encountered racism
in public society and so what Grebo is
basically doing here is using the
character of Marlene to reflect the part
of society who were raised isolated from
such intense racism and had no idea of
how rooted it was in the rest of the
United States because Adam consistently
took the high road despite the fact that
he could have obliterated any of the
races individuals he had encountered
Marlene's affections grew and that to
her eyes Adam was everything a man
should be and that he was honorable
intelligent and compassionate and so as
time passed contact was eventually
severed between herself and her superior
allowing her to give herself completely
to Adam and cast aside her mission but
for Adam all of the information revealed
here is more than he can bear and now
the personal struggles he endure
required that he walk away from being a
hero for Earth but that despite it all
the one person that he could rely on was
his wife but after the revelation of her
role in his life despite the affection
she claimed to have developed over the
years in the end Adam feels as isolated
and alone as he did when he left the
White House after being asked to step
down and so faced with the facts Adam
makes a decision to leave his wife due
to her deception and so picking up on
the blue area of the moon the story
shifts his focus to the relationship
between blue Marvel and The Watcher not
for me this is probably one of the best
moments of the story and that this
discussion allows for an outpouring of
blue Marvel himself with The Watcher
arriving his experiences monitoring the
multiverse and all occupants within have
provided him with
valuable insight into the nature of
people as such his argument here is that
Marlene is only human and makes mistakes
just like everyone else furthermore blue
Marvel is talking out of anger here in
that to him
he confided everything in Marlene but
because The Watcher sees and knows all
blue marbles claim has a fault as The
Watcher forces him to admit Adam only
revealed to Marlene what she needed to
know and so in truth his actions are
really no different than hers and so
following this between their discussion
the problem blue Marvel faces is that on
one hand he has to deal with the fact
that he has to return to his position as
a hero in order to safeguard against the
anti man but on the other hand all he is
known from society is mistrust and to
see ranging from society itself to his
wife and so transitioning to the shield
Helicarrier above New York the
conversation between Reed Richards and
Tony Stark reveals that the anti man has
returned furthermore the atmosphere is
beginning to grill with antimatter
energy me that anti man is growing
stronger by feeding on its power and so
as the story begins to come to a close
Tony Stark is greeted by the arrival of
Adam Brashear who sought out Tony Stark
and we received those a way for him to
help bring an end to the actions of anti
man
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and I will
catch you guys later
puse